hey we have a little surprise for you
it's coming right now
hey
[Applause]
look who's back
yeah
yeah
yeah
where are them babies at they're
downstairs with my dad and he's by
himself with them this is great sona you
uh
you have not been on the podcast since
you gave birth
to two human beings it really hasn't
been that long though i think it's only
been like six weeks and you were on the
last episode something we had
pre-recorded but it's still so nice to
see you you look amazing you know what
this takes the drama out of it it does
let me let me explain to the listener
that for us we have not seen sona in
eight weeks or something on the podcast
we haven't seen you because you gave
birth to two human beings yeah um and
you're a mom now but because we
sometimes shuffle things out of order
people probably heard you on the podcast
last week yeah right today matt i don't
know on the michael keaton episode yeah
so so basically people think you're a
terrible mom oh god come on yeah the
impression out there is that you gave
birth and then an hour later started
doing commercials for fracture and uh
casper masters or whoever kentucky fried
chicken people that don't uh buy ads
anymore um how are you i'm good am i
right i'm okay i don't sleep much but i
think you know that's uh why don't you
sleep
because the there's babies that are uh
i have to feed them we have to yes
that's all handled by others is i'm
remember no no no no no how many yayas
are currently at the household right now
actually there's that's the problem is
there's no yayas there's a dead dead one
day okay can we use i'm sorry we're in
america now
let me help out here your father yes um
and and then and of course yaya
is uh is a grandmother it's a
grandmother so my uh
i love them and i need them but they
never had a conversation with me about
it they just
started showing up like the day after we
got back from the hospital
they just came
and then i'm told your mother didn't
even use the door she walked through the
wall and there's a hole in the wall
that's the shape of your mom
she just walked right through the wall
and grabbed both babies isn't that true
yeah she walked in like the kool-aid man
and then she just took one of them took
the babies i don't see them and then uh
at night uh tax parents come so they're
the night shift and then they leave and
then jack and i take care of well not
the night they take care of the evening
they're like yeah but you're getting a
ton of help yeah so do you sleep during
the day maybe no i mean like not really
no they're just i can't like just turn
it off if they're there and they like
need me and i have to hold them and
i mean
you're not sounding very maternal you
know it hasn't clicked in yet huh yeah i
think like i know they need me and i
have to hold them i just i'm ready for
them to be fun they're just like
drooling and you know
but they're great i like them a lot i
love them i mean i love them what are
their names
uh mikey and charlie yeah mikey and
charlie i knew that i just want p i
don't want people to think i'm a monster
i did know that but i wanted the uh
listening public to know that it's mikey
and charlie
do you do they have armenian middle
names they do they what are your middle
names charlie's is creek and uh
michael's is tanya krikyod crecod it's
like gregory but it's creek
creek yeah just for the record is
nothing like gregory
yeah
i love how in armenian you can say
what's his middle name grab stadium
you know it's like tim
how is that like tim what's his name
grubstrand
you know billy
do i miss this i don't think you do you
should go i need to go what's that
they're crying oh no they're not i don't
know
mama i know no i'm having a baby just to
get out of this
i know i suspect that people are faking
having babies just to get away from me
because i keep hearing uh sony you had
these babies but i never see any sign of
them and and then i see pictures of you
online vacationing in different hot
spots around the world
yesterday you started we were on the
phone you started doing a bit that was
annoying and i was like what's that i'm
pregnant again remember i just yes i
just i'm gonna just get pregnant
whenever you annoy me okay well sorry
set some kind of record listen i'm
i'm worried you're not getting any sleep
at night but let me tell you this babies
until three months
they don't do much you know
but then when three months hits they're
going to start to lock eyes with you
yeah smile
my kids at three months recognized me
they were like oh [ __ ] that's conan
o'brien wait they recognized you as
their father or they recognized you as
like a public figure like oh no they
just knew me from the 90s they
they totally recognize
yeah they were like oh [ __ ] you know the
early stuff was so good the kids it
turned out were very familiar with my
career so long before they knew me as a
father they knew me as a guy uh who was
on late night and um yeah syndicated
briefly on uh cnbc
in the early 2000s um so right now
you're deda your father my my dad
they're a dead day okay what do you call
him pop what what's the armenian way to
say father baba so you'd say he's your
baba he's their dada what do you call a
bottle then if you don't say baba for a
baby
yeah bottles in my family were bubba
wait what until two years ago and
sometimes when i really hit the bottle
it goes back
baby bottle you'd go baba no why do you
assume matt that everyone said that
that's just you i guess what do you mean
that's what babies call a bottle baby i
thought that was something that that
people did that that was kind of like
dada mama baba
well i'm sorry to have offended you all
my children were very verbal they would
say liquids please
and that was it that was it three weeks
liquids please for nourishment that's
what my daughter said it three weeks
okay and she wore a monocle